i went to the chargers game on sunday oh
you're a football guy now yeah no
you sure no i would say i'm less of a
football guy now oh okay why
because nfl just sucks live
yeah most sports are not that great live
sucked what was the stadium was sick
though yeah
sofi
oh denim what
sofi stadium it's pretty cool the one in
inglewood yeah yeah brand new
like
crazy the whole thing is like
super vertical vertically stacked so
that like everyone can see the field so
interesting like it just feels when
you're in the nosebleeds which is where
our scenes were
it just feels like you're
like three stories or more like above
everything else that's cool wild and the
the the screen have a 360
big screen with screens on the inside
and the outside oh so you can see it no
matter where you are in the stadium it's
pretty [ __ ] crazy
but yeah the games just sucked
who did they play
uh the giants
i mean spanked them the giant spanked
the chargers yeah i mean you know i'm
about to get a lot of hate but uh it's
the
chargers i mean they're not they're not
a terrible team no sorry the chargers
spanked the giants sorry
they're not we bet on the giants
so i got spanked oh so that's what
you're upset oh here i am talking [ __ ]
about the charges and they're eight and
five they're not
they're not a bad team it just felt like
i don't know just felt like everything
i know the chargers came from san diego
right yeah but like did the fans also
come
because it just it just felt like all
the [ __ ] was so forced
like bolt up and all the sayings like oh
no i think it's only been in la for two
years well i think i just felt like
everything they were doing was like
these new traditions that they were
trying to like make a thing you know i
wouldn't
doubt that that's what it was i a lot of
people were pissed that the chargers got
moved um and for a while people would
comment that
they could just tell the chargers fans
in la like didn't really give a [ __ ]
yeah
so
i mean they do but it's because
everyone's blacked out yeah
everyone there was so [ __ ] up yeah
that they're all like [ __ ]
do you even know what you're saying yeah
what does bolt up even mean yeah was
that the saying for the chargers in san
diego
no i think no because they changed the
logo right it used to be like a
i don't know i don't know what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about
football fans are cringing right now no
the the old slogan used to be um bolt
these nuts in their mouth
that's what they used to say in san
diego yeah that's a way better saying
than built up
the guy would get on the you know the
announcement get on the radio to the
stadium all right chargers fans let
then they came to l.a and then l.a was
like we're gonna do a little bit
different
i'm gonna make a little bit more
welcoming you know something that the
kids and the moms can say we're just
gonna go with bolt up
[ __ ] that dude
[ __ ] l.a
so there's this dude
this group of people in front of us all
of them are blacked out right it was
like this these two guys and these two
girls and clearly like they were married
to each other you know yeah they were
they were two couples yeah and the dudes
were so drunk
that they were standing up and like
every once in a while the guy would like
turn around because there was he was
wearing chargers jerseys and there was
like giants fans behind us so he kind of
like turned around to like try and mock
them or whatever
and we were behind him so he'd turn
around every time just with this
horribly like just glazed over look like
this
and he'd be like looking at like giants
fans like trying to mock them and we're
looking at this guy like this guy is
looking like i don't even like through
the stadium he's no idea where he is
and the guy the guy beside him was doing
the same thing
but was so drunk that he was like he
kept like patting his girlfriend on the
shoulder like is it like go giants like
look at what they're doing
and was so drunk that he didn't realize
she was bawling her eyes out to her
friend
so she was like clearly
just like in ruins about something i
don't know she's like bawling to her
friend and his her boyfriend is so drunk
that he's like just grabbing her
shoulder and like moving it like look
what's happening on the field sounds
like a really healthy situation it was
so funny sounds like everyone's getting
what they need out of that scenario yeah
wow
yeah live sports
did a whole like bit about this [ __ ]
live sports is such a spectacle man
it's so
it's funny depending on the sport how it
is
like baseball is funny to me because
i feel like baseball has
these unique things where the stadium's
been there since 19 something and it's
like multiple generations of people have
come to that stadium so they have like a
certain like entitlement about how the
game and the stadium should be and how
people should act and they just treat it
like their own [ __ ] living room and
you know they're just they're just
looking for someone to put peanuts on
the wrong part of the floor yeah
yeah yeah i don't know it's funny but
did you have a good time no
i didn't
it sucked honestly
it wasn't fun at all football no
commentary i think is
it's kind of uh yeah
you know now that we're at the ball it's
just so much better to watch live yeah
but going to the duke game in vegas that
was
that was so much fun
yeah because the energy is better and
it's just like more action
yeah football sucks
i'll take
this guy goes to one [ __ ] game and
says all foot life football sucks cool
dude yeah
i'll stand by that
football sucks
come at me
what happened in oh but the [ __ ] mma
fights this weekend oh my god yeah such
a good card mm-hmm
yeah it was not that nunes fight was one
of those yeah that was
i had like a i've had a dark feeling for
a while that amanda just has been
checked out and understandably no one
has come close to
putting her in danger yeah
um
and
uh shout out to
pena she got
she got amanda to be flat-footed and
just take it on the [ __ ] face and
i have a feeling amanda's not going to
come back no yeah i feel like she's just
fine
it's just yeah i lost whatever
because
she's just been dominating for years and
years and years
finally she's like yeah finally i know
what it feels like yeah she just wanted
to lose one time yeah she's like yeah
i'm out yeah i could see it
but uh the oliveira fight was was great
it was good yep um it was definitely
good it's you know two two title
attempts and both you you got
subbed yeah which is which is rough that
was the first one khabib ah
so now it's interesting is khabib has
been coaching
um and
he's been coaching this kid islam and uh
he's really confident that islam will be
the the next
champion to take you know take out
charles
um i think justin gaichy is going to
fight next i don't know that whole
division is killers but
um this sets a very interesting stage
the fact that charles won i think
charles might be a champion for a while
because he has that he has that psycho
belief in god um
you saw you saw what you said within 30
seconds of winning no he's like he's
like looking like a [ __ ]
video game character
in a you know a post fight sequence you
just yap into the camera and then when
they finally get a mic up to him
they're like what did he what did you
say what'd you say
and he's like uh uh these guys talk
i do you know he's like
you thought this that that and then he
ends the sentence with but it was him
the whole time points up to the ceiling
oh no he's like yeah yeah
yeah no one's coming close to that
no one is [ __ ] with that for a while
yeah that's that's pretty funny
that's pretty funny to be the best
fighter you it's like you got to
relinquish belief in yourself
oh yeah you have to has to come from
another place
that's the only way you can get like
inhuman ability yeah
is to believe believe that abilities not
coming from yourself yeah
yeah that's kind of deep
it is
it's pretty deep to suck someone
multiple [ __ ] times in the face yeah
uh and then
and then
restrict their breathing and then think
like god did
that is
something else like god's upstairs with
a [ __ ] xbox controller yeah
b-a-a-a-b
all right choke them out yeah
swivel grab l1 r1 yeah
so crazy
because that's terrifying you get in the
ring and that dude is just like looking
through you like i'm gonna do this for
jesus yeah whoa i am a vessel yeah
for a high higher power like yeah
like yeah it's just like a meat
a meat shield yeah
he's not a puppet he's literally a skin
suit for jesus christ yes yeah
it's actually crazy that jesus from
heaven is just
through the ether just suiting up and
beating on humans
he's just stepping into other humans
like like just [ __ ] pacific rim and
he's like yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] this
dude that's how jesus gets it out this
is so fun it's beating the [ __ ] out of
my creations
you